bonsoir david alors à quelle annonce
peut-on s'attendre mais déjà ce qu'il
faut savoir sophie c'est que comme vous
l'avez dit les chiffres sont alarmants
et que le confinement actuelle elle n'a
pas à l'effet escompté et veyran la
colère d'olivier ferrand il ya deux
jours dans l'hémicycle témoigne une
tension palpable au sein du gouvernement
ce qui est la conséquence des mesures
plus drastiques vont être prises et
annoncées d'ici une demi-heure
ici au ministère de la santé dans le
concret c'est la fermeture à 22 heures
de certains commerces points de vente à
emporter ou épicerie qui est génère des
attroupements cette mesure devrait
concerner paris et la petite couronne
comme annoncé par anne hidalgo une
mesure demandée par le préfet de police
est soutenu par la présidente de la
région ile de france valérie pécresse
autre point d'inquiétude ce sont les
cantines des lycées où des centaines de
lycéens affluent chaque midi dans les
cantines
conséquence sans masque en plus la
plupart du temps une solution de paniers
repas avait été étudiée mais trop
compliqué à mettre en place ce qui est
en revanche étudiés c'est l'alternance
des des lycéens entre des cours distant
ciel et des cours présentiels
l'inquiétude en tout cas et 2001 pour
l'ensemble des médecins et qui réclame
un confinement plus strictes tout comme
l'opposition politique
c'est le cas du maire à christian le
maire républicain à christian estrosi
qui réclame un confinement semblable à
celui de mars avec des écoles qui reste
quand même ouverte
si beaucoup d'avis de qualif